former bachelor Ben Higgins and his  fiancee Lauren Bushnell get candid about  saying I do to a TV spinoff  et spoke with the couple Thursday where  they opened up about hesitations with  doing their new freeform show Ben and  Lauren happily-ever-after  you'll get a peek at our lives after The  Bachelor saying quote at first when the  idea was presented to us there was some  worry there our life isn't going to  change at all it's just people are going  to be with us as we're going about our  daily routine though Lauren admitted her  life will be changing on the career  front going from flight attendant to  lifestyle blogger and Ben possibly  running for a Republican seat in the  House of Representatives he gushed I'm  very excited and now it's the right  opportunity when asked about wedding  planning Lauren revealed the couple are  focusing on the wedding let's hope they  get it on tape another day we just want  to get married  you